so I'm just going to jump right into it
with the series ending um what was your
favorite part about being in this show
was it the close was it the time period
the people that you're working with what
was like the biggest highlight this show
is like my Star Wars like uh I've been
obsessed with it since I saw the trailer
years ago 2017. so uh all of it has been
very exciting I'll say more specifically
um yeah the costumes were amazing
the cast is amazing
um working with Amy and Dan has been
just the highlight of my career so far
it's all been really really incredible I
mean I would love to wear some of the
clothes that you guys wear on that show
because they just they blow me away
every time I see it
um we get a glimpse into Dina's life
um as a black woman operating in this
white world and there are a few moments
in this series in the season especially
where we see that she sort of takes a
stand rather than ignores some of the
stuff that happens
um especially with Susie's clients was
that a storyline that you enjoyed
exploring and was that something that
you felt was fitting for your character
for sure I loved exploring that side of
Dinah I thought it was very
representational of like life like of
real life and I like how
Amy and Dan like we didn't harp on the
fact that this is a black woman working
in this white world we didn't harp on it
right but when it came up it was
addressed and quickly squashed and life
moved on
um yeah so I really enjoyed tapping into
that that part of Dinah for sure yeah I
mean it was great to see and obviously a
lot of your scenes are with Alex and I
love those scenes that sort of dynamic
that you guys have together is very um
it's very entertaining to watch and it's
infectious was there someone in this
series that you didn't get to have a
scene with that you wish you could have
had oh sure I would actually loved to
have had scenes in the oh wait I'm about
to lie I did have a scene with him
um never mind let me change that I would
have loved to work with Caroline
um uh Shirley maisel oh my goodness I
just think that she's brilliant a
brilliant actor and the character was
just so entertaining I would have loved
to see what their Dynamic would have
been yeah for sure I mean Shirley is
also like such a who to be like whatever
she's on screen she's like 90 of the
time she's so funny I think I just I
don't know how anybody stays in a scene
and is there an aspect of Dinah's
character that we didn't explore in this
entire season that you wished we had
more time to maybe go into I mean yes
and no there's always like hope for more
more time more explanation exploration
more story lines to tap into but on the
other hand I am really satisfied with
how everyone's story wrapped up this
season I think it was done really really
well and just you know speaking about
your role and of course this character
in getting into this character is there
something that you took away from this
experience and you know what was the
biggest I guess like lesson that you
have after working on this project this
project really helped strengthen my
memorization skills really helped train
my tongue into like articulating like
really making sure I'm saying full words
and I'm not chopping off the end of my
words because I'm from the south and I
love to chop a word off
um let's see what else
I don't know just um
going play being in a period piece but
keeping it very relevant
still very like fresh and modern
um yeah all of it yeah I mean for sure I
mean what was it like I guess had you
done any period pieces before this and
was this sort of your first experience
with it no I've done some period pieces
before on stage and you know if I could
go back and do them again I would
because I'm like oh you don't have to
play it like it's a period piece like
these people were just living it just
happened to be that year you know what I
mean and that's uh something that I
really learned with maisel it's like Oh
no you're not playing like it's the 60s
this is just a woman who's working and
growing her life
and it just happens to be in the 60s you
know what I mean so yeah for sure I mean
I can definitely I feel like there's a
sort of modernity when you're watching
the characters on screen especially the
way that they're talking and sort of the
dynamic that we see it feels very like
believable to us here today rather than
very sort of like uptight and Posh sorry
that I think we all have like of the
past like old-timey sort of like oh I
expect them to be very like put together
but people have been people forever you
know so yes absolutely
well amazing I love that um I absolutely
enjoy I love this series so much like
you I'm a huge fan and it's such a
delight to see you on screen
um I really want to thank you for
speaking with me about this and yeah I
can't wait for everybody to see the
season me too
thank you thank you bye